if you look at when you scout the themes
that people
will put on the youtube and the videos
that we see on the main muslim channels
people try to avoid the topic of
intimacy they'll talk about like zinna
and this person committed zinna but then
they don't talk about why they committed
zinna or what the issue is
they'll talk about like you know our
children are going astray
and look what's happening but they're
not talking about
well wait a second why why is that
happening
and how do we address this issue how do
we fix this problem
[Music]
if you feel like you take things too
personally if you feel like you get
triggered too easily
if you feel like you're taking things
too seriously um
then you you probably care too much
about what's going on around you you
probably care too much about what people
think about you what people say about
you
and all that stuff and at that point you
really just gotta zone in on you
figure out what it is that you want to
do with your life invest your energy
into that
and that way your energy is not going to
be
so available for others
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims podcast
i'm your host rami with fayad and angel
and today
we have back our amazing brother brother
gabriel assalamu alaikum how
so today we have a very important series
that we're starting called the intimacy
series
now you might hear me
colin because she herself wants to get
intimate these days
uh she has not been spayed unfortunately
but this just goes to show how important
intimacy is to all
uh biological creatures but
why is it important to muslims i thought
it's something that
you know practically doesn't exist until
you you're married
i thought it's something that we should
avoid at all costs or we don't talk
about
because it's taboo or to i thought it
was you know my crew or this not the
other no
this is actually very important and
here's why if a man and a woman
are not pleased being together
intimately
that marriage is going to break apart if
that marriage breaks apart that family
breaks apart and if you have this all
throughout the community
the community eventually breaks apart
now this may seem like it's superficial
to all of you
but look at the divorce race today look
at how people are suffering today
single-parent households and uh
witnessing their their mom and dad fight
all the time
this is the big problem and it actually
starts
with intimacy it may start much further
than that actually down the road but
one of the biggest components is
intimacy and this is something that
brother gabriel talks about a lot
so if you want to take the mic away by
all means
okay
first and foremost for yeah being real
about this topic and it seems that
as you said it is taboo in the 21st
century muslim ummah
yet it is something that surrounds us
everywhere
i believe pretty much everywhere you
turn you'll have some indication of
how important uh important this topic is
be it that you're driving on the street
and you see an advertisement it seems
that today
pretty much everything that's being sold
there has to be
some kind of indication
of some sexual connotation or using the
female body or the male body
to promote this product be it that
they're you know shampoos or
pair of tires for cars or whatever it is
you find some kind of connection between
that
and the you know one of the genders
the opposite gender mostly women are
used
because they're more aesthetically you
know pleasing supposedly
and they're used for that so sex is
something that
is is very important for the world why
well because it is a
primal instinct is a basic thing that is
how we
ensure the continuation of the species
has made us
one of the meanings of the word khalifa
is a generation that continues to
go okay it's one after the other right
so it's not just a vice gerund or as a
leader on this earth but khalifa also
is someone who continues to you know as
generation after generation after
generation
and we find that the muslim community in
the 21st
century is facing a very interesting
challenge
we are okay to
[Music]
you know push aside theology we're okay
to
uh question so many things i mean i
think 2020 has been a very
very um interesting year there's been a
lot of
controversies within the umma in the
west there's been a lot of things that
we talked about tied to lgbtq
and so on right imam's coming and
support of these
groups not necessarily saying that's
halal or anything like that but you know
saying that
you scratch my back i scratch your back
but when it comes to intimacy everyone
gets a bit like oh my god you know they
really just say the word
sex right and i've gotten quite some
heat for it
and last time i think one of my last
videos was reading from kitab
nika in sahil muslim which is the third
most authentic book after sahih
bukhari and after of course the quran
and i was reading some of these and some
comments you know i usually don't read
the comments because
they are quite negative and you know
people are
sometimes they affect you right you're
kind of like my god you know why would
the person say this
but i read some of the comments and some
people are saying look at how
shameless this person is to talk about
intimacy or look how
he has no shame to speak about sex so
openly
and this is like someone living in a
western country so wherever you go
outside you'll find
um that there's indication of sex you go
to the shop
i don't know what you guys have 711 or
you know
whatever and you'll find that there are
magazines in there fashion magazines or
fitness magazines that show or have you
know men's fitness
women's fitness they'll have always a
section on sex
and yes indeed muslims do
look at these things and i recently
released the video
i think i called it holier than the
prophet salallahu salem syndrome
and i think that's one of the problems
that our community is facing is this
this concept that we're very holy and
the open yet inside we are struggling
i'm not going to say it's a hypocrisy i
think it's just a natural thing that's
happening where we're trying to maintain
a certain image on the outside
in the social media right how we preach
we talk about a lot of things
alhamdulillah these are good things no
doubt
but being a counselor and dealing with
some things firsthand
i would say that the ummah is very
different inside and we are
suffering and as rami said that
yeah it is it is one of the most
fundamental
important subjects when it comes to
marriage and before
marriage right so a lot of the couples
that are breaking apart
they are breaking apart because they're
not
intimate enough or properly
one way or the other subhanallah when i
deal with my clients
it will reach the issue of intimacy and
it'll either be that this person's too
selfish or doesn't pay attention to me
um they we're not connected and so on
it will start from like money or you
know issues of communication
but when i and i do push this question i
ask them usually like so how's your
intimate life
and they're kind of like uh it's
horrible
and i'm like but why be like we're not
connected
why because well you know this and that
so
bottom line we're having an issue where
on the
outside we look very religious very
pious our discourse is brother if you're
allah
alhamdulillah we fast we pray the
speeches that we hear that there's about
taqwa and about you know jannah
and this is all good alhamdulillah it is
great i'm not putting those things down
because i don't want people to think
that
but if you look at when you scout the
themes
that people will put on the youtube and
the videos that we see on the main
muslim channels
people try to avoid the topic of
intimacy they'll talk about like zinna
and this person committed zinna
but then they don't talk about why they
committed zinna or what the issue is
they'll talk about like you know our
children are going astray and look
what's happening
but they're not talking about well wait
a second
why why is that happening and how do we
address this issue how do we fix this
problem
so people say again like look we should
fear allah of course
no doubt there's no doubt about the
concept
of taqwa and how we should be better
muslims and how we should pray more and
be
and fast more and how we should control
our desires
no doubt about that but is that it
and i'm not saying it as i'm asking the
questions from my perspective
i would like to summon the seer of the
prophet salallahu
because when you look at the life of the
prophet sallam in the sahaba
that's when you get context so yes a
sheikh or a scholar can come and say
call allah rasul
and this hadith and that ah yeah that's
great but to contextualize things it
takes it a step further
so when you understand for example when
was this revealed and what was the issue
and what did the process do that's why i
believe the study of seerah is so
important so you can actually
contextualize these things so then you
find that wait wait a second so
is talking about intimacy something
wrong well then you find the hadith of
the prophet sallam where
a woman comes and asks him about the
issue of
wet dreams do the women have wet dreams
which is to an extent tied to what's the
female orgasm
okay which was a myth for a great amount
of time within the
western society within the western
circles the
the female orgasm was a myth and it's a
big problem
and until today we're having issues with
that that
men some men um do not know
the the uh female sexuality
and don't understand it um so we find
other hadith for example where
the sahaba just made hijra they moved to
medina
and there is a
intermarriage you can say between some
of the muhajiri
people who are coming from mecca and the
ansar the people of medina
so the custom of the people of medina
was that they would have intimacy the
position would be from the side usually
okay so it actually says you know from
the side and it's it's a position
you know so but so the sabbah were a bit
confused so they had to go and ask the
prophet saws
like
he said sorry i mean i don't know i mean
i think we should have a disclaimer
right like what is it like right there
or like over 18 or what what do we do
here because
like omar khattab said something like i
think he compared it to like
um his camel you know like something
like
you know i don't know i'm trying to find
here the right words so it doesn't get
us in trouble
uh it was something like i wrote
they like i wrote my ride
you know something like that you know it
was like you know
tough you know so so i think the prophet
saws clarified the issue of
a position again like was it from the
back and not
in the back if you know what i mean
right so it's not like anal
so then he's you know it was like don't
worry like it's okay you know it's like
it's it's fine you know like that's
that's the one thing
that it's okay to do it from the back
but not
in the back if you know what i mean okay
so this is not
not the one that is permissible but it's
permissible the position
from the back so what i'm trying to say
here i don't want the brothers and
sisters to misunderstand me
but these are taken from a hadith this
is not like i have some dirty mind
i want to talk to you about you know
these things because that would take a
whole different turn
we're talking here about what we can
extract from the sun of the prophet
salla
sallam and from the intimate
discussions that has not only made into
the corpus of the hadith
but have been uh taught and given ejazin
and the wives of prophet sallam for
example would tell us about
some of the intimate moments and things
like that so for example
in the chapter of the qiyam of the
prophet saws
narrates how the prophet saw would split
his night
right so he would sleep for one third
okay look at this mashallah like
very very uh disciplined so he would
sleep for one third
and he would wake up and pray for one
third
right and then this is narrated by his
wife
okay this hadith is narrated by his wife
and then
the prophet saw sallam if he wanted to
if he had the need he would be intimate
in the last third of the night
okay and if he didn't then he would go
to sleep and he would wake up at fajr
but if you would be intimate then he
would you know come and be intimate so
he would
sleep pray and be intimate
okay so even some of the scholars
the one of the commentaries of the
hadith says that it's great to have
a sex in the early hours because you've
digested all the food already and you
feel very light and it's quite
a good sensation and a lot of strength
and so on
so again what i'm trying to point out
here
is not to have a you know rated r
session
but is to say that the muslim uma needs
to re-examine this
problem of feeling shy
when it comes to sexual education
because it's causing problems so let's
state the problem the problem is that
many brothers and sisters
in a world that is hyper-sexualized
everywhere you turn
everything you open everything you
scroll in if you open your instagram you
go on reels right now you have reels and
you just kind of
flip through it or whatever you want to
flip you're gonna see something there's
no doubt about it
okay it's just you're gonna see
something you go outside
in the street you're gonna see something
you open the tv
you're going to see something you you
walk on the street you're going to see
something
you will see something that is related
to or
pushing you to feel attracted to
the opposite gender it's just the world
that we live in
look around the world is i mean
you know where we're we're dropping our
clothes
so the youth muslim non-muslim
are confused you have a generation of
very pious
muslims you know the generation of the
uncles
the masjid leaders and then you have the
youth who are
living in the society and they're asking
questions they want to know and you know
how early that is that is as early as
seven six seven eight nine you know
some parents come to me for counseling
and they say my child is 12
13 and uh you know i caught them
watching porn or you know masturbating
or something like that i'm like what can
i do and i'm like it's too late
because they're it's not the first time
they've done it
and they're like what do you mean it's
too late i see i should have started at
seven you should have start talking
and making sure these things they
understand slowly these things
because they're already exposed to it by
the age of seven i'll give you an
example
living in the western countries the
schools are already exposing them
at the age of seven eight and so on it's
in the curriculum
there's been some crazy attempts from
some of the scandinavian countries
to you know do things with children
experiments and
in the curriculum cartoons you name it
so
yeah it's going to be there it's going
to be there so the more you kind of try
to turn a blind eye and be over pious
and
you know think this is taboo and we
cannot talk about it
you know it's wrong and so on okay
fine but they're still gonna get it
they're still gonna get it
so my argument if is if the prophet saw
sallam
was open and the quran talks about it
the sunnah talks about it
sahabas were very young were learning
these things
um the non-muslim society is talking
about it
yet the muslim community is saying no
no no no i don't think i want to talk
about this this is very shameful
uh my father didn't do this to me so i
cannot do this to my son
okay but still it will happen and they
will get the wrong
information they will get the wrong
information their fitra will not be
nurtured
and at that time in those formative
stages
when you give them the wrong thing you
have to understand there's an
association
your body is already wired
for intimacy it's just the way you are
from your physique your body to your
brain
and the two being connected so what
happens is
that when you have the first experience
of intimacy or pleasure
be it that it is an actual act of
intimacy or just
seeing one or hearing about one or
talking about one
and it is within the wrong concept
and you associate that pleasure with the
wrong schema
or the wrong image of it i.e for example
i had a client who
was a young girl and her her friend were
snooping around in her brother's
things and they found some sorry annie
porn that was lesbian and that was the
first
ever exposure of her and her friends two
young girls
seeing any intimacy and since then
they have been basically their minds are
on to that
and they consider themselves
heterosexual but they say we are very
attracted
to the same gender to the woman because
when i saw that
intimacy between two women it was it
raised some
emotions into me that associated with
the act and the pleasure and
it was at a certain time that i was i
didn't know anything about this this was
the first time i've ever seen this
so i am attracted to that and
almost addicted to that yes i want a
husband i want a man i'm also but
i cannot get that out of my head i
needed to bring that example
to make it clear as to what can happen
okay so you see these kind of accidents
can
damage the fitra of young children
so what should have happened is that if
this girl would have been talked to
by her parents or the com you know
whoever
they would have said that for allah turn
away
move away right but they were curious
when they saw it they saw the cover
they were curious to understand what it
is they pressed they played they looked
and looked there was more curious
there was no nothing no voice in their
mind to say
mom is saying i shouldn't look at this
dad is saying i should look at this
this is incorrect because a woman and a
woman it's not
even if it would have been a man and a
woman it would have been zinna you know
what i mean i'm just trying to bring
some
some context to the problem so these are
some of the
issues that we're faced with and if
we're not going to talk about it
within a educated
um i can say somehow safe environment
um from an academic perspective
with educators how to teach maybe
teachers parents what's the right age
how to approach it it will happen no
matter what
it will happen brothers and sisters
unless you live
on some mountain somewhere with no media
and even then your fitra and your
hormones
will be bubbling at some point that
it will come subhanallah imagine your
mind if you're away from any of these
things
your mind will start creating these
images
and that's what is the manifestation of
a wet dream as the prophet saw
i'm explaining right so you've never
seen it but your mind sees it
your mind constructs it and that's what
results into what's called the wet dream
because a wet dream has a climax
so in this wet dream usually there's the
the
the person be it girl or boy they see
the act of intimacy
and that is why it's called the wet
dream because there is
wetness that is associated with meaning
i.e climax
so the mind is wired for that
you understand and it is wired very
early and it is one of the signs of
puberty as
ulama talk about actually the ulam and
that's probably one of the most
and i'm sorry i'll i talk too much i'll
pass the mic back
that is one of the most interesting
if not surprising things that
the ummah considers the previous
generations more
conservative yet we find that the ulama
like ibn hazem and others who have
written books extended
who have written books about intimacy
and love and the fukuha specifically
when dealing with the chapters about
tahara impurity and
uh many and and you know about they
should do sperm and
i mean they've talked about these things
and citing some of the hadith of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam
you know and it's like it's you know
when you read it it's like
wow you know like it was like like i
shot all the allah you know she narrates
that
she would scratch the dry
semen from the
from the clothes of the prophet sallam
and this is how we know that if it's dry
it's taher it's not najis from this
hadith
extract the ruling right
that she would scratch you with her nail
and then he would use the same cloth to
go out to pray in the masjid
people would be like oh my god you know
but this is the reality right this was
them
this is the olema talking and here we
are fast forward to the 21st century
muslim community
whose children are going astray
committing zina becoming gay
lesbian what not dating
you name it in muslim countries yet
their parents are living in a bubble
putting out a overly
pious you know image and denying that
this is a problem
and if anyone dares to talk about this
issue they will say this person is a
dirty person as a dirty mind
how dare them talk without shame like
this in public
you know someone says you should write
in a book you shouldn't be talking a
video a video is too
graphic and i was like subhan allah look
at this is it this is
24 i mean that's where they're reaching
your children to video
so if you look at the statistics um
pornography statistics uh 2020
uh they were released i know and again
the muslim um when i talked about these
things they said man
you know this is like it's a conspiracy
against the muslims and i said it's not
just the muslim
they release the statistic for the whole
world
right not only the type of porn that
people are watching the genres of porn
but the amount of porn they're watching
and yes women are up there watching it
almost as much as men now before used to
be like
much less now it's up uh men are
watching
so about you know you can say now it's
like in the 80s for
men and about 60 70s for women
supposedly
but of course women don't report as much
as men it could be definitely more but
from what they've taken in terms of
statistics that's where we're at
and uh the the type of pornography that
people are watching are very
very alarming you know when you look at
it's quite shocking especially women
and i've talked to some women counselors
who deal with women only
to try to understand this issue i've
done a little research on about 50
muslim women with regards to the type of
things they watch
it's quite an issue there's a
collaboration but again people deny
these things
and they they think that people are sick
to talk about these issues
but the real sickness is is what's
happening in our communities
and that we're not able to correct this
and yeah so i think
we look back in history it was not an
issue for the fukaha
the books were written the ulama talked
about it
yes mashaallah maybe even the quality of
intimacy was much better maybe that's
why people are staying more together
and now we're suffering divorce
you know cheating zinna and and
and yet we're denying it
now back to you
just in time to hear my uh my cat yell
on the back
but um i mean
usually any talk any like idle useless
talk
is something that should be avoided
regardless so people
are talking about things like this
uselessly then yeah you could say what
do you
why you know why are you talking so
uselessly about something like that
especially if you're talking about your
own intimate life and it's just useless
yeah
but if you're seeking advice education
if you're educating your children if
you're educating the youth if you're
educating a 30-year-old man who never
got this education
it's necessary it needs to be done
because if you look at the greater
scheme of things the greater picture
like we were talking about you will
actually present a lot of societal
diseases that come about marriage
divorce
just being one of them just being one of
them
but uh unhealthy what are your thoughts
so far anything to add
man i would i would literally just add
to the marriage now do you think that
infidelity that's another thing
yeah yeah
and brother gabriel you said something
before that that actually
got me thinking of it you said that
maybe the quality of intimacy was better
back then
and it just it had me thinking like i
heard there was some
like some sahaba that wouldn't be able
to see their wives for a while
and when yo later outside man bro
let it get some outside
[Laughter]
it's a lot for her bro i know
you got her suffering in the house so i
had the same issue with my cat
yeah i spit the heck out of her about a
week and a half ago
and she's just out there in that little
cone bro
she's wearing that cone because cats
like to bite their incisions
yeah and bro i can tell you from
firsthand that
her drive her energy i haven't even
heard her meow since done bro
wow must be traumatized
he basically took her soul basically
marshall up
humbly she's more pious now she's more
she's more pious than the
the the guys uh watching that are
looking at gabriel saying brother what
are you talking about you know
my cat's more pies than you guys
but uh now that she's quieted down a bit
um there was some sahaba that you know
they would get excited you know just
just seeing their wife
right and we've become so desensitized
because of things like you mentioned
like porn and scrolling through
instagram just seeing something like
that
it's supposed to be something where it's
like wow you know like oh it's finally
happening
not oh you know i saw this on on this
video once right
when two people get together and do this
thing
and it's pornography and this is
desensitization
that's effectively ruining intimacy
because not only does it create false
expectations because i've heard stories
of
of men who um because these these women
they
do a lot of things for the body things
you probably won't even think about
in all aspects so when a man sees you
know a natural woman
you're like that's not what i saw here
they have all these weird expectations
and then when they're not doing the
things that and she's not behaving the
way that you know he would
see in the video again expectations like
what is this
and he's displeased with her and then he
just goes and he sticks to that video
and on top of that you have a literal
library
compared to you have your one wife right
it's so toxic and it's so
damaging especially for the wife who has
to go through that if she's not the one
indulging in the pornography
this is something they didn't have back
then something that is something they
didn't struggle with back then but that
alone
if you add on all the other issues we
face today uh
like it we're in some deep water so this
is why
you know the the speakers and scholars
should talk even more about this
relate it back to the sun of the process
you don't have to talk about it from a
secular perspective that doesn't matter
at least you know it's getting out there
you're talking about it from a point
where it's not just
this is haram don't do it and then call
it by
right bring the alternatives talk about
marriage talk about
um why it's haram talk about the side
effects talk about where it could lead
people
uh but it's unfortunate this is
something that just
people aren't talking about today which
is why we started this series i see
i see that smile on another's face which
in the case bro
you might want to go in on some but let
me just say this off the rip
if you're a heterosexual man you're
straight
your t count is even semi-normal
if you see a naked woman
your wife that alone should be enough to
do it for you
like to want to get intimate you
shouldn't need all these things that
you know today you see like toys and
gadgets and
weird things and extra things and you
know she has to get all these surgeries
come on man
let's just take a second to admire
romney's beer coming in
mashallah
i think it's super necessary to talk
about these things
and if people start getting triggered or
say something like ah brother
that's not modest that's not pious like
you shouldn't be speaking like this
i'm sorry but that's just that's a soft
individual that's a
individual who's not living in reality
and it's like look
if you're married or if you even if you
haven't gotten married
like ask yourself that question like how
important is
the intimacy because gabriel said it
best if the interes
the intimacy isn't there the
relationship isn't going to last that
long
because then you no longer have a
relationship between a man and a woman
you have a friendship
and we both know or all of us know how
well friendships between men and women
last
that's right that's right actually
subhanallah
one of the uh i say this to my clients
and to people if intimacy is good and
compatibility in terms of their faith is
good okay i think every other problem
can be solved
so financial issues um
you know problems between families
there's always going to be problems
there
right you always have couples coming to
us for counseling and they say we have
issues here we have issues there
couples that have strong you know faith
bound
like they're bond together by islam
they're they're compatible in there
not one is practicing one is not one
praise one doesn't
it doesn't work like that okay so if the
two are masha'allah compatible on that
point
and obviously they're they're loyal to
each other
and they have a good intimate
relationship like their intimacy is
healthy
they can solve any other problems man
like issues of money
whatever you know they had problems they
have arguments
no matter what okay um even arguments
right you can solve it with some good
intimacy you know it's like
some of the best right so it's it's
really good i mean it's
so healthy and that's why the main thing
the main one the main objectives
actually or the main objective
of nikah is intimacy
so when you make your nikah the first
thing that happens is
that she becomes halal for you right and
it is linked to intimacy
so there's one time a sister asked the
sheikh
is it all about
she basically i've heard it it was
basically something like this
is is marriage all about sex and the
sheikh was
quite masha'allah he was he was an elder
mashal and he literally looked and says
it is you know he said it is
he said indeed it is and and he just
said look this is like one of the main
objectives of course you have other
things
but basically what he said is that if
that is clean if that
is healthy that is good then everything
else works
okay because that's the first thing why
is it a sunnah to consummate the
marriage
on the wedding night right why do you
consummate the marriage why do you have
the walima
after the consummation this was the sun
of the prophet you know if it wouldn't
be if intimacy is not important
then it'll be like let's take two three
weeks after we make our nikah to get to
know each other
we can have a good conversation and you
know
that's not how it works you know i mean
intimacy is what connects
the two together it is what unites
the the couple it is what brings them
together
problem is that it's been distorted the
concept of intimacy has been distorted
for those who are coming from the
non-muslim background like angel and
myself
maybe we can relate to this more because
we have a past
in the you know the jahilia what we call
we know like this is like normal
for for people i mean growing up
in in you know north america
forget even when i was in europe if
you're like if
if you're a young guy like just in your
teenage years you know
13 14 and you haven't lost your
virginity or not done something you're a
loser
you know what i mean like your friends
are gonna make fun of you
right um it was not strange to walk on
the hallways of our high school and
and hear stories of conquest and this
and that and you know you name it
and this is this is how the the
non-muslims work and how many muslims
live in non-muslim countries be it usa
canada australia
uk right i lived in muslim countries as
well
i taught as a teacher in muslim high
schools in muslim countries conservative
countries
and the talk about intimacy was
all over you know what i mean so because
it is part of the fitra
so i think the objective of this series
with our brothers may allah blessed many
okay the three muslims is to to raise
awareness
but also to give some solutions to the
community who's willing to if they're
anyone i'm coming from an educational
consultancy background being a school
principal
a teacher for many years and i like to
give solutions to parents
to communities right i want them to look
at these series and say okay these
brothers four guys have talked here
they didn't just talk about sex but they
talked about how
we can understand this issue how we can
overcome this taboo
you know feeling how can we
look at preemptive measures and how to
train our children
to protect themselves but not just that
to slowly
push them through the natural
development
to express and to understand their
sexuality as they develop
because hey again think about it
brothers and sisters
parents when your child has his first
wet dream or when the girl has her first
wet dream
when the girl has the first period and
she doesn't know to turn to she falls in
shame for example
and she's you know she's so embarrassed
why
why do we keep hearing these stories i
mean trust me man being
and i've taught in both all boys and
mixed schools as well and i cannot tell
you how many times
girls have their periods or get their
periods at school and how embarrassing
it is because they don't know
they have no clue they don't understand
okay what it is and how it is because no
one has talked to them
so what we're trying to do here is to
find solutions how can we have
preemptive measures how can we teach
their children our children within
our system our ethics and morals
to understand their sexuality and their
development their
physical development what it means what
the fukuha have talked about because in
the sharia there's a huge
difference parents pay attention
there's a huge difference between
someone being
a um to be a you know pubescent and
to hate puberty and not in the hokum of
the sharia
in what's implemented in a crime or not
in terms of a punishment it makes the
difference between
uh you know even life and death all
right so
the fukaha were very explicit on these
things
so what we're trying to say let's
understand and also
also damage control and let's i think
a lot of the time we're going to talk
about damage control because
trust me uh a young man in his 20s has
already been exposed to these things
converts like myself angel others who
are converting to islam
daily to islam right they're bringing in
a luggage with them
you know they're they're luggages of
sexuality and experiences from the past
are they to be written off meaning them
the people
not their past experiences allah has
removed those
and they're not accountable for them but
sorry you can maybe
be forgiven but sometimes you don't
forget isn't it
it's it's very hard i mean for me i
don't know angela i'm sure
it's hard to forget what's happened in
the past man and that's who you are
today it's called your total past
learning history in psychology
we call it the total past learning
history every stimuli
every bit of information that you've
been exposed to you've seen you've
experienced you've tasted
it is what you are today it is a sum
of who you are today so that has to be
addressed there is a lot of people
how about the ones living in the west
versus the one who are not
these things need to be understood again
with the objective of hopefully
hopefully learning and being able to
either reduce
prevent heal deal with these issues
so that the family union is saved and
that intimacy can be practiced
healthy and be enjoyed
and that a family that is based on love
will be raised out of that and children
will see their parents
being in love and expressing love of
course within the permissible boundaries
that that is so fundamental to their
upbringing because one other thing that
happens in these overly
pious families and i'm not saying that
i'm not trying to use it as a negative
thing that people are pious
but they don't show love and care
amongst each other parents don't show
and the process would hold his wife's
hands and he would show some
some affection towards them and
you know and towards his children but
parents don't they think it's taboo
again
and that is so fundamental for
the healthy emotional
sexual development of a
child you have no clue my dear brother
what it means for you as a father to
kiss your daughter
and to hug her for her to feel that
masculine
love at that age of course it's a clean
thing
as a father but for you to embrace her
and to tell her that she's beautiful
versus some scumbag on the street who's
going to take her attention
because you haven't given it to her
because you think it's haram or it's
overly or you know you're
very like it's taboo or you're very
pious and your culture doesn't allow you
to
and as the prophet sallam said to that
you know that man
who was kind of surprised when he kissed
his grandchildren and he said what
should i do if allah removed
the mercy from your heart he says you do
that
you kiss them right so how important it
is how important it is for a father to
understand
what it means to say to your daughter
you're the most beautiful girl in this
world
and give her a hug and a kiss and even
to your son to say you're handsome and
to hug him
even that masculine love gives him some
confidence and he's not going to be
doubting his sexuality because he's
experienced he knows what it means to be
touched by a man and hugged by a man
and to feel love from a man that he
trusts
versus being in his teenage years and
doubting his sexuality or not knowing if
he sees a handsome guy or something like
this
oh i'm confused now let me try to
experiment or i heard that
you should try this so you should try
that and then he falls into that trap
okay people need to understand how
important this
is this talk people need to acknowledge
the you know our bravery to speak about
this topic
and it might bring a lot of heat but who
cares because i hope
and past in the previous episode that
we've done brothers
i'm telling you man the feedback
ninety-five percent of the feedback
okay is so amazing so positive
it's just amazing like i'm messaged by
mothers
saying jazakallahu hair for you guys
having some guts to talk about these
things because i'm a mother of three
boys
and this is so important i'm a mother of
two boys or five
boys or you know three girls and two
boys
and what you guys are talking about has
opened my eyes
and now i'm able to finally not feel shy
about it because you guys quote quran
and sunnah
and we see that this is it and
alhamdulillah you know they're thanking
us
as for the other people have other
opinions may allah open their eyes to
see
the importance of this inshallah
inshallah that would be a beautiful
ending with the episode inshallah for
today
i just want to read one verse from the
quran to finish off what you're
mentioning before
allah says in the quran and of the
sciences that he created for you from
yourselves mates that you will find
tranquility in them and he placed
between you passionate love and mercy
indeed and that are signs for those who
prefer a people who give thought allah
says he put passionate love
now you can fill in the blanks of what
passion the love is in your in your
own head and mercy two necessary things
for marriage to thrive so may allah
allow us to be the people
to lead the righteous and to teach
people that this is not a taboo thing
may allah allow the muslims to have
good proper marriages to raise good
proper children
insha allah so we can have allah i mean
any last thoughts from you guys
all right with that being said allah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]